are you stuck looking for a sweet spot
between user connection speed cloud
hosting performance and the buffer
window you use to request data well
you're in luck because today on cloud
storage bytes we're exploring the Venn
diagram that is performance and we're
gonna find that overlap stay tuned
if you're a company that streams data
performance for you and your users is
going to be a reasonably huge priority
let's say you're a company that's
looking to duplicate your content for an
international audience your architecture
setup is pretty simple currently serving
data directly from Google Cloud Storage
to users on mobile and desktop let's
take a look at how you can go about
optimizing your window size so you can
ensure consistent buffering to all of
your clients no matter where they are to
make sure we're on the right track we'll
need to profile how the read performance
adjusts at various window sizes of
download you can test this by writing a
small script create a regional bucket
create a bunch of files at a bunch of
sizes upload them and download each file
100 times via an HTTP fetch request with
caching disabled if you run this script
you'll see that there are consistent
results for files smaller than 1
megabyte which we already knew from
previous episodes and if you run it
again but tweak it slightly using a
larger file fetch through different
chunks you'll see that as chunk size
decreases the transactional overhead
increases and slows everything down as
we know already Google Cloud Storage is
very powerful in terms of single stream
throughput and write throughput meaning
that for both uploads and downloads
Google Cloud Storage is optimally
utilized for a quest that are no smaller
than one megabyte in size otherwise that
all-too-familiar transactional overhead
is gonna bog things down again with this
information you can better determine
what level of regional redundancy is
needed for serving your video content
and you can optimize for the one Meg
Plus Google Cloud Storage target to
improve your buffering speeds there's
plenty more to come about optimizing
performance but we're gonna go ahead and
save that for another time if you want
to know more go ahead and check out the
links in the description and don't
forget to subscribe give us a like and
tell us what you want to learn about
Google Cloud storage
thanks for joining us for this quick
byte of cloud storage see you next time
[Music]